actress Ellen Page who now goes by
Elliot has a new book out and
coincidentally has revealed that she was
the target of a transphobic attack
sometime last year
according to Paige a year ago a hateful
stranger approached her in West
Hollywood yelling quote I'm going to
effing gay bashu f-a-w-g-o-t
at which point he chased her into a shop
screaming this is why I need a gun
now this incident that we are for some
reason only hearing about right now
obviously happened a long time ago
but it is being reported that police
have released a sketch of the alleged
transphobe and he appears to be two
Nigerian bodybuilders from the south
side of Maga country news reports have
not specified whether or not miss Page
was able to hold on to her Subway
sandwich during the harrowing attack
perhaps that detail is included in the
book that she is now Hawking
I'm not saying for certain
that it didn't happen
Hollywood has always been weird
terrible political leadership has led
the crime problem in Hollywood get out
of control a friend of mine
shortly before we moved out of La was
threatened on the street by a bum with a
crossbow okay there are freaks out there
for sure
but even more than criminals and bums
Hollywood is filled with fabulous and
narcissists people with a very tenuous
grip on reality
it just seems unlikely okay the big red
flag in Ellen Page's story is that
phrase gay bashing
no heterosexual uses that phrase that is
a phrase that is used exclusively by
leftists and LGBT positive activists
it's the biggest sign of a Hollywood
imagination run amok
unfortunately for us that Holly weird
imagination is run amok all over our
country and as is especially clear
during pride month
large numbers of Americans can no longer
tell the difference between fantasy and
reality I'm Michael knowlesis the
Michael and old show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by my very good friends
over at good ranchers great meet at a
secure price 30 off your order with code
Knowles kwles go to goodranchors.com use
code Knowles today really big news on
the presidential campaign front can't
wait to get into that and on the media
front Tucker is back baby Tucker is back
on Twitter he's got very interesting
things to say about Ukraine about aliens
about terrorist attacks so we will get
to that in just a moment
first though the pride month update
today is daily pride month update comes
from mayor Pete who was asked why those
mean nasty conservatives
would have the gall to criticize certain
aspects of the Rainbow Coalition the
gestapo and here is Pete's answer
well our country is a very real risk of
backsliding on freedom and equality but
that is exactly why we continue to push
there has been extraordinary work that's
been done just in this presidency uh
certainly the president being able to
sign the respect for Marriage Act for
example and if you zoom out to the
progress that's been made in the last 10
or 15 years including the ability of
somebody like me to be standing here
doing this job it's extraordinary and
yet now you see the attacks on the lgbtq
community especially on the trans
community and what they are going
through and you know I think it's being
done out of a perception that it is
politically convenient to Target
vulnerable groups and and honestly I
think where it largely comes from is
folks who don't want to talk about why
they were against the infrastructure a
law that's building the roads and
bridges they don't want to talk about
why they were against 35 insulin that
the president delivered for Medicare
recipients they don't want to explain
why they uh were for these radical
positions that speak to what people are
worried about in their everyday lives
yeah that's it Pete that's it the
Republicans the Republicans are speaking
out against transiting little kids
pumping them full of poison chopping
their body parts off because we're just
so afraid of our opposition to an
infrastructure law
yeah that's it
we know that the people are strongly on
the side of building some new bridge
somewhere and we've got to run away from
our radical opposition to
insulin reform by focusing on this
really minor issue that no one's really
interested in namely the fact that
Democrats are trying to chop kids
genitals off that that's it you hit the
nail on the head
we just don't want to talk about the
real hot button issue Paving roads yeah
you got it Pete I don't know I think it
probably has more to do
with the fact that people around this
country especially parents but
just pretty much everybody
realizes that it's probably not a great
idea to turn innocent little kids into
Unix and sterilize them and chop off
their body parts I think that's probably
why can you believe can you guys believe
how radical the Republicans have become
Republicans didn't even want to pursue
the printer kind of of pharmaceutical
insulin reform that I that I was
advocating for whoa that's some crazy
stuff huh okay Chop Chop get that kid on
the operating table let's go give me the
scalpel
um
I I don't I don't even know what the
insulin reform was I don't even know
what stupid infrastructure regulation
people judge is talking about but I'm
willing to bet I am willing to bet every
dollar to my name
that if you had these three types of
legislation before you
regulate the price of a diabetes
treatment
build a certain kind of bridge instead
of another kind of bridge
chop off a child's genitals I am willing
to bet every material possession that I
have
the the last one is going to be the most
radical and that's why and that's why
it's not just Republicans who are
opposed to it it's why normal people
centrists even a number of leftists all
around this country even the feminists
even a lot of people around this country
realize that that is a very very bad
idea that seems to be the more likely
reason
and on that point even as the people are
pushing against trancing the kids the
liberal establishment especially through
the judges are coming in to preserve
that Sacrament that sacred right of
progressive liberalism speaking of
sacred rights you got to pray if you
want to have a flourishing life and when
you pray
maybe you want to check out hallow right
now go to hallow.com Knowles it is very
clear that the libs are giving up their
morals and common sense if they ever had
any there is no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you were thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
increase overall well-being hello is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it has helped a lot of
people maintain a daily prayer routine
it can help you too download the app for
free at hallow.com Knowles kwles you can
set prayer reminders and track your
progress along the way are you not sure
where to start well check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year my
favorite podcast available on the Hallow
app for brief daily readings and
Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and even some
world-class athletes not myself included
not yet at least with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions using
Halo to connect with other who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community ultimately we will
learn how we can become better people in
spite of today's broken World As We
strive to become more like Christ in our
daily lives to prayer fasting and giving
download Hello at hello.com Knowles get
an exclusive three months free three
months absolutely free at hello.com
Knowles
federal judge
has just struck down a law in Florida
that would ban doctors from prescribing
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
to little kids
why did the federal judge strike this
down
he struck it down
because he says
that gender identity is real
that's why that's the whole reason he
struck it down the judge says quote in
His Name by the way is Robert Hinkle
he says quote the elephant in the room
should be noted at the outset
gender identity is real the record makes
this clear what record I don't know
nobody knows
he says despite
the defense admissions there are those
who believe that cisgender individuals
that meaning people who understand who
they are properly adhere to their natal
sex and that transgender individuals
have inappropriately chosen a contrary
gender identity male or female just as
one might choose to whether to read
Shakespeare or Grisham
and this is false because gender
identity is real
this is obviously going to be headed for
the Supreme Court you're seeing a lot of
liberal judges go in and overturn laws
passed by the representatives of the
people duly elected representatives
representing the people's will to stop
quacks from trancing little kids
the judges come in and say no it's
unconstitutional not to pump kids full
of poison and sterilize them and chop
off their body parts so this is
obviously headed for the Supreme Court
not great for us because even this
conservative Supreme Court has affirmed
transgenderism you saw this especially
in the Bostock decision where judge
Justice Gorsuch who is a conservative
came in and said that civil rights law
that provides protections on the basis
of sex
actually secretly provides protections
on the basis of gender identity which is
ironic because if the civil rights law
protects gender identity then it very
much does not protect sex
if
if the civil rights law says that men
have the right to play on a girls sports
team then it it undercuts what the civil
rights law was actually intended to do
which was to say that women have the
right to their own sports teams separate
from men because you can't you can't
have both and even a conservative on the
Supreme Court sided with the
transgenderists here so this is not not
great news that it's headed to the
Supreme Court because the court just
judging by precedent judging by the
Harris Funeral Homes case that says that
civil rights law means that a man has
the right to wear a mini skirt at a
funeral home if he wants to to express
his quote unquote gender identity that
that's not great news
it would be really nice if the people
could answer this question themselves
wouldn't it would be really nice if if
the people were able to say no we
actually don't think that men can become
women we're going to enshrine that in
our law and we're going to say don't
chop up little kids
but but when the people have done that
the liberal establishment has come in
through the courts through the
unaccountability of the Judiciary to
come in and say no actually never mind
somewhere in the Constitution it says
that men have the right to pretend to be
women
and and parents and quacks have the
right to poison their kids
oh the civil rights law yeah even though
we know for a fact that when the Civil
Rights always passed nobody thought the
protections on the basis of sex were
protections on the basis of gender
identity or whatever because that
concept didn't even really exist at the
time yeah well anyway now I'm just
deciding that's what it is do you see
how
do you see how circular this argument is
from the Judiciary
they're saying
sex means gender identity
because today
a significant portion of the people say
that sex means gender identity not the
majority of the people certainly
but
a decent number of the people including
me we say that and so that's obviously
what it must mean for the purposes of
the law even though the law was written
60 years ago and so that's what we're
going to do
gender identity is real why because I
say it is okay there it is all right I
guess we're just ruled by
this dictatorship of some random federal
judges
it would be really nice if the people
had to say here not only for a
procedural matter not just because I
think that vox populi is Vox day you
know the the voice of the people is the
voice of God I don't really care about
the procedure I want good government
whatever whatever just procedure leads
me to good government that's what I want
if the judges give us good government
then let the judges have to say if the
people are going to give us good
government let the people have to say if
the president's going to go then okay
let the president have to say but the
people happen to be right on this the
people tend to have much more common
sense especially today where our ruling
class is entirely liberal the people are
almost always right when they disagree
with the ruling class and you see that
here okay you're getting some political
pushback even on the right
the presidential race is heating up some
Republicans hate this stuff I love it
some Republicans are pulling their hair
out no why why is this candidate
attacking this candidate no they
shouldn't do that they should all get
along that's not what primaries are for
primaries are when really thick-skinned
really ambitious people
just rip each other to shreds
and the benefit of this is not only that
it is extremely entertaining but that
it's going to toughen up the eventual
eventual nominee so that the attacks
from the the real opposition the
Democrats will not be as effective come
the general election so Nikki Haley is
kicking this off she's attacking Ron
DeSantis over this issue of gender
identity and the the rainbow movement
she's attacking him
for turning on Disney
here you have DeSantis who accepted 50
000 in political contributions from
Disney
he went and put their Executives and
their lobbyists on prominent boards
throughout Florida
and he went and basically gave the
highest corporate subsidies in Florida
history to Disney
but because they went and criticized him
now he's going to spend taxpayer dollars
on a lawsuit it's just like all this
Vendetta stuff we've been down that road
again we can't go down that I businesses
were my partners in South Carolina we
didn't always get along and I you know
luckily South Carolina is very anti-woke
but when you have a company like that
don't bring the citizens taxpayer
dollars into it pick up the phone deal
with it settle it the way you should and
I just think he's being hypocritical
I like Nikki Haley a lot personally
she's very nice nice lady this was an
ill-advised attack on DeSantis because
the attack ends up making DeSantis look
good she's saying DeSantis received a
lot of campaign contributions DeSantis
worked very nicely with Disney and put
Disney on on certain boards and gave
them some influence but then when Disney
opposed the
elected representatives representing
their people and the law that they
passed to stop transiting the kids then
DeSantis turned on Disney
so her attack is that DeSantis is not
totally bought and paid for by his
donors
specifically Disney
which ends up making DeSantis
look good
I think the point she was trying to make
is that DeSantis is showboating here or
he's disrupting business in a way that
is not
conducive to the flourishing of the
state or it's just nationally
self-serving but doesn't serve Florida I
don't know I don't know because she
didn't make that point instead she says
Hey DeSantis we'll take donations from
people but then not just do whatever
they say so
if I were running the Haley campaign
right now I would retire that line of
attack I don't think that is going to
gonna work very well but it is a Taxis
so the attacks are all going to come out
and the attacks are going to come out
against DeSantis they're not going to
come out really against Trump
you're seeing attacks from Vivek
ramaswamy uh against DeSantis you're
seeing Nikki Haley attack Ron DeSantis
you're there's one candidate who is
attacking Trump
brand new candidate in the race we'll
get to in one second
but the attacks are going to come
against DeSantis because Trump is so far
ahead in the polls right now that if you
just try to attack Trump then he's going
to Nuke you from outer space and your
campaign's going to be dead in the
Cradle
you got to go after DeSantis to weaken
DeSantis so that it ceases to be a
two-man race and it becomes a gigantic
candidate versus all of the other guys
then they can all turn on Trump which if
2016 is any any indication
will probably occur once it's too late
which is why Trump likely right now will
receive the nomination but the one
candidate who is attacking Trump right
now
is the new candidate in the race he's
the dark horse that a lot of you have
made fun of me for suggesting could have
a moment in the campaign
it's the chrisons baby it's the
croissants for sure it is Governor
Christie
you might have forgotten about him but
he's popping back up and he's officially
filed paperwork to run so he hasn't made
a formal announcement but the government
as far as the government is concerned
he's a candidate for president he said
he's going to run as the chief Trump
antagonist he said I am running my
campaign just to attack Trump which is a
big deal because while a lot of
politicians in the Republican Party have
bad blood with Trump going back a long
way Christie and Trump used to be
buddies
Christy was an advisor to Trump during
the 2020 debate prep for Trump and Biden
Chris Christie was Trump's sparring
partner
which tells you two things one Christy
was pretty close to Trump and two
Christie's a pretty good debater
he's the guy that Trump World picked to
be the toughest Challenger to prepare
Trump for that debate
and now things have changed in the last
few years Christie is really going after
Trump specifically going after Trump's
family
let me tell you something everybody the
grift from this family is breathtaking
it's breathtaking
Jared Kushner and Ivanka Kushner walk
out of the White House and months later
get two billion dollars from the Saudis
two billion dollars from the Saudis
you think it's because he's some kind of
investing genius
or do you think it's because he was
sitting next to the president United
States for four years doing favors for
the Saudis
that's your money
that's your money he stole
and gave it to his family you know what
that makes us a Banana Republic
that's what it makes us
so he may get 30 again I'm not sure
maybe he'll get more maybe he'll get
less but let me tell you what he'll know
in 2024 that he had no idea of in 2016.
he's in for a fight to get it
okay
that's not very persuasive
what do you mean Trump didn't know he
was in for a fight in 2016 there was a
brutal presidential race and there were
a bazillion people running
but Christy has a point which is that in
everybody reserved their fire
well the people who attacked Trump got
nuked immediately and then the
candidates who were trying to come in
number two they're maybe trying to wait
until the very end to Edge him out they
held their fire until it was too late
you saw this especially with the cruise
campaign showed the Rubio campaign
so now Christie's coming out there he's
saying look at this grift from this
family now it's tough for Christy
because Christy was very close to Trump
and he helped Trump for a long time
including up through the 2020 election
so now is Christy running a Liz Cheney
kind of campaign oh I've seen the light
I used to do lots of terrible corrupt
stuff with those awful Republicans but
now I've seen the light no he's not
quite running that he's not quite
running on how close he was to Trump but
he's he's not quite running on it being
an outsider in Trump World he the
message is a little bit confused
and so he's going to get in the race now
and
what complicates us even further is the
only thing Christy can do in this race
is help Trump
he can't he can't really hurt Trump
there is not one single Trump voter who
is going to vote for Christie over Trump
unless they throw Trump in the gulag or
something and Trump's not available for
a campaign
so Christy even as he targets all of his
attacks on Trump he's still running in
the anti-trump lane
Christy is still the alternative he is
an alternative that is more acceptable
to The Establishment because his
policies are a little more liberal
significantly more liberal than Trump's
but he's got that fight
and so it's in a way it's a kind of a
smart campaign pitch which is on the on
the guy who can take on Trump Christy is
dealing with the political reality that
this is Trump's nomination right now
look at the polls this is his to lose
and so okay
the only guy who's going to have a shot
is going to be the guy who explicitly
says he's going to take on Trump that is
where he's running and I know you doubt
me
he could have a moment he could have a
moment I have a lovely moment
very often
several nights a week where I get to sit
down and I have a delicious meal very
often provided to me by good ranchers
right now go to goodranches.com use code
Knolls this Father's Day let your dad
unleash his inner Grill Master whether
he prefers a sizzling steak or savory
grilled chicken look no further than the
gift of meat from our friends at good
ranchers good ranchers has the best meat
in the business period I love it sweet
little Elise is a wonderful cook and she
makes all sorts of great meals even
without good ranchers Meats but we eat
good ranchers Meats a lot of the time
and I'll tell you those are the meals I
really really look forward to okay good
ranchers offers Ribeyes and New York
strips T-Bones all natural Burgers their
burgers are so unbelievably Next Level
you can't even imagine it all the most
delicious chicken you could ever want
plus right now you get 30 bucks off with
code Knowles at goodranchers.com they
offer a price lock guarantee for the
next two years which is insane given the
rights of inflation here if you had
locked in your price two years ago you
would have saved hundreds of dollars
you're not sure how to grill the perfect
steak well they've got tons of recipes
head on over right now make your dad
very happy this Father's Day go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s for 30 off any box promo
code Knowles goodranches.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
if you're looking for something
interesting to watch check out the
series what we saw hosted by Storyteller
Bill Whittle season one is focused on
Apollo 11. now season two of what we saw
is in full swing in episode 13 President
Nixon's visit to China introduces a
three power Dynamic but
the Watergate nontroversy undermines his
administration
and diminishes American morale the
Soviet invasion of Afghanistan further
exposes American weakness in this
context an older president brings
renewed optimism youthful vigor and a
plan to end the Cold War
and Achieve Victory after four Decades
of stalemate Bill makes you feel like
you were there witnessing history hear
this amazing story in this week's
episode of Cold War all episodes of Cold
War are now available to stream but you
have to be a daily wire plus member to
see it go to dailywire.com Cold War to
start watching
so you got Haley attacking DeSantis
Christie attacking Trump now Rubio
Rubio's not even running for president
he's attacking Christy
Rubio is furious because Christy's pitch
is hey I destroyed Rubio's campaign I'm
gonna do it to Trump this time
and you remember there was that Great
Clip I didn't pull it today I should
have it but a lot of people have been
Googling it over the last 24 hours where
where Christian Rubio run a debate stage
Rubio gave some canned 30-second speech
about how we need to dispel what this
fiction that Barack Obama doesn't know
what he's doing he knows exactly what
he's doing and he goes on and it was
some rehearsed line and Christy made fun
of him for it he said that's the thing
that's wrong with Washington says that
thing the canned 30-second speech it's
so stupid it's ridiculous and it really
flustered Rubio and so Rubio sputtered
for a little bit and then
he repeated the line he didn't know what
else to say so he repeated the line and
Christy just demolished him for it he
said there it is there's the line again
okay here you go proves my point it was
devastating it was devastating so Rubio
out of nowhere
tweets out any political reporter
commentator claiming Christie ended my
campaign in 2016 is lazy or dumb New
Hampshire debate sucked because instead
of hitting back when attacked like I
wanted to I listened to advice about
pivoting and not punching down on Chris
Christie who is at seven percent about
to drop out but it didn't end my
campaign after New Hampshire I finished
second in South Carolina in Nevada won
three primaries almost one Virginia on
super Tuesday finished with the third
most delegates behind the Trump's
historic campaign and was elected
reelected twice by 8 and 17 points okay
Marco it's all right
it's all right okay this is not
ah
I like Marco Rubio
but
this is a weak sauce man his defense is
one I didn't follow my instincts and I
listened to whatever the Consultants
told me so don't blame me it's the
consultant's fault okay come on that's
not that doesn't make you look good and
then two
it's not convincing anybody
in fact all this tweet is making people
do is go look up this very embarrassing
moment for Marco Rubio and there's a
political lesson here for all of us I'm
not just beating up on Rubio the
political lesson is don't try to fight
yesterday's battles yesterday's battles
are over and you either won or you lost
and if you
lost then you're not going to win by
rehashing a loss people are just going
to be reminded that you lost
and if you won
you actually can lose somewhat by
rehashing it if you're going to reopen
that issue and reopen that victory
then people are going to analyze it
again maybe because political
circumstances have changed they're going
to re-examine maybe maybe change their
perception of what you've done
you can't win you've got to fight
today's battles you've got to fight on
today's terms you definitely don't want
to remind People for People in politics
for anyone who's got any kind of an ego
who's got any kind of a sense of Pride
or you know wounded dignity or something
those moments where we screw up where
you said the wrong thing you did the
wrong thing you just oh you feel queasy
that you've got so much regret they
stick with you forever and you think
that if you just keep bringing them up
you can you can fix it you can't just
move on
just move on don't make people Google
the worst moment of your political
career now speaking of battles and
presidential candidates Vivek ramaswamy
is going on the offense here he's not
merely attacking the other candidates
Vivek was on ABC News
he was asked by Martha raddatz to
explain his position on Ukraine and
Vivek went a long way to differentiate
himself from the rest of the field
you do not believe that Russia taking
over Ukraine would be bad for our
national interest I do not think it is a
top foreign policy priority for us I
don't think it is preferable for Russia
to be able to invade a sovereign country
that it's its neighbor but I think the
job of the U.S president is to look
after American interests and what I
think the number one threat to the U.S
military is right now our top military
threat is the sino-russian alliance I
think that by fighting further in Russia
by further arming Ukraine we are driving
Russia into China's hands and that
sino-russian Alliance is the top threat
we've faced and what I've said is I
would end this war in return for pulling
Putin out of that treaty with China no
one tells Vladimir Putin what to do what
I think we need to do is end the Ukraine
war on Peaceful terms that yes do make
some major concessions to Russia
including freezing the current lines of
control in a Korean War style foreign
wouldn't want to do and also a permanent
commitment not to allow you and tornado
but in return Russia has to leave its
treaty and its joint military agreement
with China that better advances American
interests and actually further deters
China from going after Taiwan
it's a great plan it's a great plan and
it is the
best specific plan that anybody in the
race has laid out on the Ukraine war
now some people might knock Vivek the
only way they could knock Vivek for this
answer is either if they're total
warhawks who just want NATO expand to
expand around the world and just want to
conquer Ukraine that some people the
establishmentarians will do that
but
the the other criticism would be well
you know you've shown your strategy
you've given up your plan okay yeah
that's true all right I guess it would
be better to play close to the best but
there's a presidential campaign you got
to tell people what you're going to do
okay and vivek's plan here is very very
good
very very good one desantis's answer on
this question was hey we'll see what
happens by 2025. yeah we'll see we'll
deal with it then so he's just brushing
it off Trump's answer was I'm going to
end the war on on day one
which is a better answer than DeSantis
answer saying we want the war to come to
an end so he's signaling here
some of what Vivek is talking about
maybe exactly what Vivek is talking
about Trump just doesn't want to give
the details here okay
why are Trump and DeSantis playing it so
safe they're playing it safe because
Ukraine is a wedge issue on the right
the base base
the the real the conservatives of the
conservatives are very skeptical of the
Ukraine war they want it to come to an
end they see Ukraine as a buffer State
they don't want NATO to expand they
don't want Ukraine to
join NATO certainly they don't they
don't want to have to fight a world war
with a nuclear former superpower over a
territory that's been contested for a
thousand years
so that the base space you know the the
Tucker audience I don't know you guys
you know the the base base
is with the vague Oneness
and I imagine with Trump and maybe with
DeSantis too he's just not being
specific
the
sort of Base the kind of more Normie GOP
voter
is reflexively
anti-putin hates Putin Putin's the worst
guy in the world
still views the world largely through
the lens of the Cold War and
wants Ukraine to win doesn't want Russia
to get a single inch of territory
doesn't have any specific ideas for
exactly how to wind this word down but
hates the idea of us giving in in any
way to Vladimir Putin so even if their
instincts are not exactly realistic or
practicable without entering into a
major war between the US and Russia
which we were able to avoid for the
whole Cold War but now who knows maybe
maybe things are dice here because we
have weaker leadership
uh
That Base probably won't like the Vex
answer and so it's a wedge issue
so why is Vivek being specific here Be
As Trump and to a lesser degree DeSantis
are way up in the polls so they don't
need to get specific foreign policy is
usually not the determining factor of
presidential campaigns
and so they kind of want to avoid it
the VAC is running an Insurgent campaign
at a left field no one knew this guy was
going to run in 2024 so he doesn't have
the luxury of of waiting on this and I
think not only is his view right
I think politically it's wise for him to
make to make this argument
yeah it's high risk but there can be
some real reward here too this is
actually exactly what Trump did in 2016.
Trump in 2016 on that debate stage was
asked about the Iraq War and all the
Republicans racks asked about the Iraq
War and they knew public opinion had
turned against the Iraq War but a lot of
them still want to defend it because
they had been defending the Iraq War for
for 15 years at that point
and Trump comes out and he says oh the
Iraq War was a mistake George Bush made
a dumb policy foreign policy error and
we're paying for it now
gasps in the room you can't upend the
GOP line on Iraq oh yeah well I did
anyway because I'm not even really a
republican that much I'm just Donald
Trump and I do whatever the hell I want
you can't say that but a lot of people
agreed with Trump's position including
in the GOP base and he was rewarded for
that
I think you could see a similar kind of
political reward for vivekier for
getting specific on Ukraine now speaking
of Ukraine war Skeptics
Tucker's back baby Tucker on Twitter
available to stream now I lost count of
how many views it has
Tucker on Twitter has got like a
bazillion views
it's a hugely successful launch
the the episode is about 10 to 11
minutes and I thought well wait he's not
doing his whole 30-minute show or I
guess it was an hour-long show on Fox
but then I remembered that when it's on
cable news half of that is commercials
so you're actually not losing too much
Tucker content it was it was an
excellent first episode and
it he went even further
than he would on cable it was a similar
kind of show but he went even further
because now he's not constrained by the
rules of one of these big establishment
news corporations
the Russians are dying it's the best
money we've ever spent Graham says a
smile spreads across his thin quivering
lips as he forms the words he looks like
a starving man contemplating a breakfast
buffet the aroma of death has aroused
Lindsey Graham thanks so much replies
zelenski he feels the same way see
there's something dark here just two
middle-aged guys celebrating the killing
of a population they don't seem like the
kind of people who'd enjoy flooding
Villages or starting a famine in any
case who cares if they are it's really
not your business your job is to support
Ukraine the media lie they do
but mostly they just ignore the stories
that matter
what's happened to the hundreds of
billions of U.S dollars we've sent to
Ukraine no clue
who organized those BLM riots three
years ago no one's gotten to the bottom
of that what exactly happened on 9 11
well it's still classified how did
Jeffrey Epstein make all that money how
did he die how about JFK and so
endlessly on
not only are the media not interested in
any of this they are actively hostile to
anybody who is in journalism curiosity
is the gravest crime
great stuff one Tucker's writers and
Tucker himself is a right he's a very
talented writer himself they're just
phenomenal that that bit about Lindsey
Graham's quivering lip as he thought
about the war in Ukraine is
a scene is so
stupid so really good stuff and then
Tucker is beginning to answer one of the
big questions about the future of his
show which is
does Tucker work without the constraints
of cable news part of what made the
Tucker show so great was that he was
saying it on cable news cable news which
had been so milk toast and reigned in
and a lot of these hosts even the
conservative ones just kind of towed the
uniparty liberal line and Tucker comes
out and he contradicts it
a lot of people on Fox News even but
throughout the cable news they wouldn't
invite really conservative people on the
air
oh no the real conservatives they're
going to be blacklisted and then Tucker
comes on he says yeah no forget about
that we're gonna have all these guys on
I'm gonna have whoever I want on the
show
well the question was does that work
when you take away the constraints and
the the answer I think is yes Tucker is
doing the same kind of show but going
further
talking about
aliens talking about foreign policy
talking about 9 11 raising questions
about 9 11. raising questions about the
JFK assassination and saying I'm going
to go further I'm going to push further
than I previously could before it's just
a way forward if this works
Tucker leans in and adapts himself to
the medium which he obviously is doing
this could be a real death blow for the
establishment long-standing Legacy Media
we're now premiering movies on Twitter
that get a bazillion views like we did
with what is a woman last week we're now
premiering presidential campaigns on
Twitter not the smoothest rollout ever
but impressive that it happened
RFK Junior now Democrat presidential
candidate using Twitter to advance his
campaign for a town hall
now now Tucker Carlson biggest
Cable News host ever
coming to Twitter
getting bazillions and bazillions of
views if this succeeds every sign says
that it has the media landscape
has fundamentally changed and changed
for the better
great we got to talk to each other about
it when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles a company
that I am proud to stand behind a
company that's proud to stand behind
this show and our whole country is pure
talk veteran owned with 100 American
Workforce they share our beliefs that is
why Pure Talk is the official cell phone
wireless partner of the daily wire that
is not the only reason Pure Talk also
happens to be the most Dependable 5G
Network in the U.S they are a top tier
provider at a fraction of the cost of
those other woke companies ATT Verizon
T-Mobile companies that don't care about
you or your beliefs actually often seek
to undermine them right now you can get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month I promise you that is less than
what you're paying now unless you're
already on Pure Talk you vote with how
you spend your money
stop supporting wireless companies that
don't support you go to puretalk.com
Knowles you will get great coverage and
save while you're doing it go to
puretalk.com Knowles you will save an
additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you
puretalk.com Knowles Pure Talk Wireless
for Americans by Americans my favorite
comic yesterday is from Edgar hoods who
says he says this of my observation
yesterday that with DeSantis running As
Trump 2.0 with DeSantis running as the
more competent Trump or the more
effective Trump
he's going to have an uphill battle
because even if he's right
many people will still prefer Trump even
if DeSantis is more effective even if
DeSantis is smarter and more precise and
More in all the things let's say it's
all true many people are still going to
prefer Trump and Edgar hoods says it's
like the taste test with Coke and Pepsi
people like Pepsi when they're
blindfolded but they like Coke better
when they can see it I think that's true
if you close your eyes
and said hey what would you think about
an executive a politician who's in an
executive role who
bans the porn from libraries and fires
Soros prosecutors and
fires the weird Pro coveted lockdown
health apparatchics and replaces them
with people who are going to take the
side of tradition and reason and freedom
and all the rest of it what do you think
of of someone who's going to take on the
administrative state or all of the rest
of the things DeSantis is focused on
close your eyes you say okay I prefer
that guy but then you open your eyes and
you say now I'm with Trump
and I'm just telling you I know they're
going to be people who like to Santas
who say well why they shouldn't pick
Trump and I know they're going to be
people who like Trump who say nah the
Santa's he's not he's not really that
good he's just only when you close your
eyes do you think he's that good I'm
just describing to you the phenomenon
and that the Coke Pepsi analogy is a
very good one
maybe Pepsi is better than Coke and
maybe it's not
many people are going to say Pepsi is
better than Coke when they don't know
which one they're drinking
but when they open their eyes and they
just look at them they're presented with
those two things
people are going to pick Coke
it's the original
that's what you're seeing in the polls
right now
and so if DeSantis or any other
candidate wants to turn that Dynamic
around
they've got to differentiate themselves
a little bit more a little bit more than
Pepsi has from Coca-Cola now speaking of
the media
something very very telling about this
whole point with the way movies are
being released now presidential
campaigns being released Tucker
Carlson's new show
there's a UC Davis study app
the UC Davis study
asks can movie reviews predict box
office success and you would think from
that question the question is if the
critics like a movie does that mean that
the movie is going to do well
necessarily and if the critics pan a
movie does that mean that the movie is
really dead
no it doesn't
actually the opposite is true
so what what the survey found was that
positive reviews
signal that a film will flop
and negative reviews signal that a film
will be a hit
this published by UC Davis just just a
few days ago
what does this tell you this tells you
about a lot more than just movies this
tells you
one we are living increasingly in a
totalitarian state
not just an authoritarian state where
the governors the rulers have a little
bit of a heavy hand a totalitarian state
where the ideology of the state seeps
heavy-handedly into everything into art
into all forms of Education into all
sorts of public rituals into the
language we're allowed to use into the
thoughts that we're allowed to have
that's totalitarian it's when it's a
total state
it would be a distinction here you could
see between
communist Soviet Union and Francisco
Franco's Spain
Francisco Franco was an authoritarian
ruler but he basically tolerated
diversity he tolerated people doing
pretty much what they wanted to do but
they couldn't insist upon it in public
they couldn't make a big show about it
they couldn't go out there and March
against his regime he would suppress
that kind of stuff but he didn't send
the thought police into your home to
tell you that you got to use certain
pronouns okay he actually had a looser
hand than that whereas the Soviet Union
would encourage people to rat on their
neighbors rat on their family the
Communist totalitarian States really
insist upon the ideology at every single
level all of the time
that's more of the society we're living
in now
because the ideology of the state is not
just coming from the congressman or the
politicians it's coming from the movie
reviewers it's coming from the
mainstream media broadcasters it's
coming from the teachers it's coming
from the sports it's coming from ESPN
it's just everywhere okay but the people
know that it's BS the people oppose it
and so
when the people see that the
establishment likes something they
assume it's bad and they won't go see it
when the establishments when the people
see that the establishment hates
something the people will go see it they
will like it
you see it on Rotten Tomatoes the way
you know a movie is going to be really
really good is when it has a very low
critic score and then it will have a
high audience score and now because
Rotten Tomatoes has has messed around
even with how the audience score works
now even the audience score isn't
totally reliable so that's that's one
thing that it tells you that's the most
important thing that that study tells
you the second thing that the study
tells you is that movies are a dead
industry
they're effectively a debt industry at
this point
the studios are churning at all the same
crap the Oscars don't reward movies that
people like the Oscars only reward
movies about like 15 year old gay
cowboys or whatever that nobody's gonna
go see
and the critics are in on it the critics
are part of the film industry the
studios are part of it the Distributors
are part of it the actors are part of it
the writers are part of it and it's just
kind of dead
and it's been it's been dying for a long
time and so if movies or just premium
content generally meaning miniseries
extended series
Middle Ground kind of shows if that's
going to have a future it's not going to
have a future in Hollywood
the future of that is going to be
outside of Hollywood maybe places like
Tennessee or maybe elsewhere this is
true of politics too this is another
reason why Trump is doing well in the
polls
I think I fear
that people who like DeSantis for the
nominee in 2024 they think I'm being too
nice to Trump
probably the people who support Trump
think I'm being too nice to DeSantis and
the other candidates I'm just calling
them like a season okay
I'm describing what I'm seeing and what
I'm seeing here is that Trump is
dominating in the polls and he's gaining
in the polls and he's gaining even after
his chief primary opponent Rhonda Santos
announces he's gaining because of the
phenomenon that you're seeing in the UC
Davis movie review study
because of the phenomenon that you're
seeing in Tucker Carlson getting a
bazillion views when he debuses his
cable news show on Twitter
it's because
negative reviews from the elites is
taken as a positive by the people
and
the candidate that the liberal
establishment hates the most is Trump
maybe they fear other candidates more
maybe they think that DeSantis would be
more effective maybe they I don't know
they're helping the Donald Trump become
the nominee by giving him so much media
coverage okay sure whatever
I think we all have to admit they hate
this guy they hate him they've hated him
for so long
because of the way he talks and the way
he is and he's so borish and he doesn't
behave like a nice fancy sophisticated
person and he's threatening major
entrenched interests on trade and
foreign policy and they're gonna they're
gonna try to stop him and they're gonna
try to cheat to stop him and they're
going to change all the election laws to
stop him and they're going to shut down
the world to stop him and they're going
to throw him in jail if they have to
stop him and if they can't get him in
jail in New York they're going to get
him in jail in DC if they can't get him
in DC they're going to get him in
Georgia Florida wherever else they just
freaking hate this guy and everybody
knows it
they hate him more than they hate the
other people
and that's why the people right now are
supporting him more
they're supporting more than Biden even
in important swing States right now
Trump is leading Biden in Nevada
Trump is leading Biden 48-47 so it's
fairly close but that's according to
McLaughlin Associates a very reliable
poll firm that's according to former
Congressman Lee zeldin's leadership
American needs pack
so it's not just well okay Trump can win
the primary but he can't win the general
at least not according to these polls
shows that and it's not even just
National polls you're seeing this in
important states that Trump's got to win
what about with the independence we're
told Trump can't win independence well
according to another survey just came
out from The Economist in yougov more
Independents prefer Trump than than
Biden
by a lot
36 Trump 26 Biden
it's a 10-point gap among Independents
we always hear about the Suburban
housewife or whatever we always hear
about the moderate voter well according
to this poll at least
and maybe it's not because of anything
Trump has done maybe it's just because
of what a screw-up Joe Biden is but
regardless people are viewing Trump as a
be likely nominee
and they seem to be
supporting him more than Biden that's
the state of the race and it's just I'm
so
glad that we're finally out of the kind
of dull season where it's just a little
attack here a little lob here a little
jab there no we are getting into real
brutal bare-knuckle politics
um
if you don't get a kick out of that sort
of thing
why do you pay attention to the news if
you don't get a kick out of that sort of
thing get another hobby go go play
ukulele or something you can play
ukulele anyway it's a fun hobby to pick
up regardless but if
if you like politics
you gotta like this stuff this is what
politics
is speaking of politics rehashing old
battles and
my producers have reminded me of one of
the one of the all-time great political
interviews
that would be Hillary Clinton on Between
Two Ferns
which we will be delving into all of the
important details of this of this great
political interview the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
become eight member use code Knowles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh